we are still trying to get somebody
uh to interview for the bitcoin
conference in miami
it's definitely gonna happen some people
are saying about bitcoin that they have
that the bottom has been reached they
think and then it's gonna climb back
up you know kathy wood you know kathy
wood of course you know kathy wood
of course do you know kathy wood of
arkansas cass
do you call her kath like i do
where does she work arc is her
and she sets price targets doesn't she
yeah she does and
a lot of them are when she sets them
kind of crazy people go we don't think
so
but then she's turned out right like
about tesla correct
interesting you you've been on the cath
wood train
uh i call her kath because i know her
for years
um you've been on the cathy train for a
long time
i was in arkg and arkk there for a while
yeah
yeah what do you like about kathy wood
you want to [ __ ] kathy wood
is that what you want to do is that what
you're trying to do mm-hmm
take your big old texas dick and smack
kathy wood in the face with it how dare
you
how dare you she's a ceo she's a ceo
i suppose yeah it's an etf right so
she's like the leader of the etf
she's the leader yeah
but there's a man there right as well
doing all the decisions
uh no i think it's just kathy is kind of
calling all the shots but she has a team
of like
people men yes okay
get nervous a little nervous there
you know it's not a flower shop
this is big business the fake business
hoodies are out we were going to wear
them on the show of course they didn't
send me my correct size why why
here's the thing i'll say the quality of
these hoodies is truly amazing
they're soft the big business jacket's
amazing
it's like [ __ ] you buy in stores it's
really great it's a big step up
i think from the merch we were doing
before which was still good but it's not
nearly as good as this
the people that are involved in merch
are a little brain dead some of these
merch people you know i mean
they're not bad people but i mean i mean
christ you know i mean you're not really
dealing with
i mean you know this isn't exactly
you know the best and brightest uh out
there in the merch space let's just be
let's just be honest about it i mean
they're lovely people
you know that's something caitlyn jenner
would say at the country club should go
they love
they're lovely people but god not that
bright
um but ben did a lot of work on the
merch
i uh i did some i did a lot too
the fake business stuff is really cool
it's really cool that people
uh dig that bit that we did and it's
very funny and it's a cool
the logo is [ __ ] amazing and
the quality of the [ __ ] is is really
good it's soft
what is it what uh is it cotton what is
it polyester
let me take this off what is it i don't
know what it is
but whatever it is it's soft and i have
very sensitive skin and
it hasn't given me a rash the this vest
is 100
polyester
well that's not that's not good is it
but it is good is it soft for this vest
yeah it's
very soft sometimes you have to use
polyester
get the hoodie see if it's caught let me
see i don't have any problems with
polyester
some people don't like it but they're
stupid
what did kathy woods say about polyester
did she say anything about it has elon
musk tweeted about it
what is the hoodie
it's um let's see here
it's uh 80 cotton 20 polyester
hey 80 20 nothing wrong with that
you need a little polyester
my mother didn't want me to wear
polyester as a child but i was a gay
cocaine addict
so they were worried about all the wrong
things they were worried about polyester
and not
cocaine and the fact that i couldn't get
enough penises
as parents he should have been concerned
about that we are working on
a book called the boomer guide to
parenting which is about the great
parenting strategies that my parents
employed with me
um and there's rules about uh
boomer parenting and we're very excited
about it and it should hopefully
you know it's a few months away from
being ready
but it's uh really great we look back at
the childhood that a lot of people in my
generation had that are in their you
know mid-30s
and we look back at a lot of the uh
tactics and strategies
uh and lack thereof that our parents
used
when raising us you know they certainly
were not helicopter parents
they were helicopter parents they
followed the kids around all the time
and they're
right uh the boomers were slightly uh
less involved they were involved in
different ways they used to drop us off
a lot of places
but a deeply selfish generation and uh
we exposed them in the book but it's
funny
it's funny all the recollections of
things like when my father told me son
never overestimate your value he was
right about that
he was right he was he was saying just
listen
don't overestimate your value if you
will do it you couldn't say that to a
kid now they'd think it's abuse
they were less right about other things
of course and that's the the majority of
the book is the things they weren't
writing about but at the end there's a
chapter where it's like
things boomers got right when raising
their kids the keys shouldn't
be a helicopter pattern of course you
don't have to go to the extreme that
they did as well
um you know where like somebody's like
my teacher's molesting me they're like
will you
shut up but there are
there are certain benefits to the way
the boomers parented
and we will get into that are you afraid
uh for the
bitcoin are you uh do you think uh i
just we just have to have it
let's start to build because we have
this convention and i don't really want
it would be funny if these people were
just throwing themselves off balconies
in miami
well i'm seeing some of these [ __ ] coins
like defi 100 are doing exit scams you
seen this
yeah well what did that what did what it
would have died what did the website
said we scammed you and you can't do
anything about it yeah we scammed you
guys and you can't do [ __ ] about it haha
all you moon boys have been scammed and
you can't do [ __ ] about it devson
[ __ ] you moon boys and they uh walked
away with 32 million in invest
investor funds
well there you go
that's what happens crypto's getting
raked over the coals i think i think the
bubble
uh which it clearly is an asset bubble
but i think people are starting to
realize that
you have one bitcoin and all these other
coins they got people
into crypto which is what i think people
liked about it like the winklevosses
were like well these other coins you
know hey
are they a waste of time we don't know
but they're getting people interested
in the crypto space and they think
long term that's really good so they
tolerate
the kind of clownish
element to a lot of the other coins uh
then there are people that are saying
that they think ethereum could overtake
bitcoin i read that
zero hedge dropped that article somebody
was saying that i don't know if it was
an analyst at goldman or somebody
i have three ethereum for my nft yeah
yeah you do
i don't know why my nft did not sell for
more i thought it was going to sell for
80 million dollars
where i dressed up like megan mccain
i mean i don't understand what is my
three ethereum worth right now well i
think you wasn't it five ethereum
it was five ethereum that's correct what
is it worth right now let me see the
price of ethereum right now
should i just give that to you and then
have you work for the rest of the year
for free
[Music]
i mean how much money does he deserve
him and his wife are constantly trying
to get more out of me the other day he
had something where he said his eyes
were degenerating
so i think she was she probably told him
when they were eating oysters
in some parking lot in texas she
probably goes you're going to pretend to
be blind and this is how we're going to
suck the rest of the money out of him
and i'm just gonna i'm gonna lead you
around and it'll make him feel bad we'll
like tug on his heartstrings you know
you're his only friend and everything
and
he goes yeah yeah i feel a little bad
about that she goes no no
don't worry about it he knows you have
glasses anyway you take them off you're
kind of blind as a bat
pretend to be blind i'll walk you in to
do the show
just just keep looking around the room
we'll give you these big thick black
glasses he won't know the difference
and then we'll tell him your eye
operation costs an insane amount of
money
we'll get it from him and then you can
you will we'll rent a
we'll do a whole thing we'll say you're
recovering at home
you know and then we'll just get the
money from them and then you can just
kind of you know go back to the show
and i i think that scam was in place
but i called it out as soon as he
went to the eye doctor i said if you and
your wife are thinking that this is
gonna work or will you pretend
to go blind and then i have to pay for
some crazy
[ __ ] experimental surgery to save you
it'll never happen
i'm not that stupid did you find the
thing i'm talking about
i know oh ethereum yeah yeah yeah so you
you have
11 845 worth of ethereum now that's
yours
thank you that's yours that's yours
that's for the that's for 2022.
that's for your work i don't know why
you keep laughing
all he does all him and his wife do is
they're just trying to
but i'm very much like caitlyn jenner
like i understand
that the parasites come i understand
what a scavenger is i understand what it
is when somebody
uh you know sees you on the side of the
road
and you're carry-on you're a carcass and
that's what him and his wife look at me
as
and they they like vultures landing on a
longhorn
how about that texas they just want to
rip
my decaying flesh off my body
and i won't let it happen